merci monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresser
directement à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé absent aujourd'hui
Madame la Ministre délégué voilà 7 mois
que vous êtes en fonction et je souhaite
entendre de votre bouche les décisions
concrètes que vous avez prises avec
votre Ministre de tutelle pour lutter
contre les déserts médicaux de tous les
groupes politiques de tous les
territoires par des rapports successifs
des débats des questions des
propositions de loi des amendements par
tous les véhicules législatifs possibles
le Sénat attend propose et exige des
décisions efficaces et concrètes pour
l'égalité d'accès aux soins de tous les
Français y compris de la ruralité
profonde
argument de votre ministère c'est
l'ensemble du pays qui fait face à une
pénurie de médecins certes mais avoir
cette conception uniforme c'est la
meilleure façon de ne pas agir car dans
la réalité certains territoires
souffrent beaucoup plus que d'autres et
le manque de praticien y est bien plus
important madame la ministre je vous le
dis
patient abandonné et mère à hier de
France ne peuvent plus supporter cette
situation inacceptable et indéfendable
ils attendent des décisions courageuses
et audacieuses qui dépendent de vous et
pas des comités machin chose qui
consomment du temps et ne ramène pas
véritablement la présence médicale dans
les territoires madame la ministre que
fait le gouvernement face à ce problème
majeur
pour vous répondre